so I had the pleasure of seeing the
upcoming path of Exile expansion called
The Awakening and I'm gonna say I'm now
really looking forward to getting back
in the path of exile the biggest part of
the expansion is that it's adding act
for so it's the first expansion that's
been storyline focused and and so the
the guys at grinding gears led me
through some of the act for content and
what's really interesting to me about
most of it is that they've tried to
really ramp up the creepy factor ray
class the world that path of exile takes
place it has always been a little creepy
but in this case they've really amped
that up and they actually told me that
their designers had gone through like a
lot of different images that creep
people out things that you normally
aren't supposed to put in games and they
they wanted to put them in specifically
because they make people feel
uncomfortable so in one place for
example you enter mines and within the
mines you see monsters that are just
pockmarked with little holes going
through them and it looks really creepy
and strange and and one of these
creatures as it turns out was actually
sort of up it was sort of like seeing
the the human centipede of zombies
crawling across the screen it was really
freaky and bizarre and that I mean
that's one part to look forward to and
you know I think one thing they're
really trying to do is put in a lot of
different variety of creatures that we
haven't seen before you should expect to
see a lot more new enemies than you've
seen in the previous acts as much as the
the act for seems really interesting to
me I think what's even more fascinating
is what they're doing to the passive
skill tree of course path of Exile has
this amazing skill tree however they're
adding something even new to the passive
skill tree jewels that can be socketed
into the tree they're going to be places
where there's no skill and you can
unlock that and then you can move a
jewel into that sort of in the same way
that you use skill gems on your weapons
I've never seen anything quite like this
some of the jewels that you put into the
skill tree actually have a radius that
shows around them
and whatever that jewel does it effects
all of the skills on the tree within
that radius you know for example if
you're working on the axe side of the
tree you know unlocking things that
improve your you're still with axes you
know you might slot a jewel into their
that changes all those things so that
they affect boats and this kind of thing
can drastically change how you play
especially when you throw in some of the
some of the new unique weapons so for
example you might get a bow that brings
into being some skeletons when you kill
the enemies that you're fighting however
if you're an archer most of the things
relating to minions are elsewhere in the
tree over by where the the witch stuff
is and so what you can do is you can use
some of these jewels that you slot into
the skill tree to sort of change how
things work it's pretty amazing I've
never seen anything quite like it in a
game and of course one of my first
questions was could this potentially
break path of Exile and the answer is
possibly it's also why the developer
supports the way its community
approaches the game with such a big tree
what they've always done is they've
always supported the idea of people
going in there trying to find ways of
essentially breaking the skill tree and
come up with uses that they didn't
imagine so they're sure that there are
things that they haven't accounted for
and they're actually really looking
forward to seeing what the community
finds it's sort of a it's sort of a
metagame that the community involves
itself in like who can find cool ways of
breaking path of Exile another thing
that I like that's being added
especially because I played as a minion
build where I had like over a dozen
things following me around is that
they're adding golems and golems is
essentially you know what pet that you
can summon that can really help you out
in your play style and I saw two of them
I saw an ice golem so it looks really
cool in action it's very agile but I
also saw one that was made of fire and
and that's uh that's a guy that stays
back he launches artillery and if
something gets too close he's got like
flames to spew out and stuff like that
and
and again all of that stuff you know
that the golem supports all of these
other changes so a lot of things that
you don't expect will happen might
actually affect your golem in action as
well depending on what jewel you slide
know there are other things coming to
there's a completely balanced I don't
know exactly all of the things that
entails because that gets into the
really nitty-gritty but it's important
to note that they're really looking at
every single thing on that passive tree
and how everything balances with
everything else and they're just
completely retooling there's a lot to
look forward to obviously there's the
new Act which I'm really looking forward
to just because of how creepy the
creatures looked but even more so I'm
really interested in getting my hands on
that new passive skill tree getting some
jewels in there and seeing how I can
break the game you know how can I make
the most powerful character I can or in
contrast how can I just make the most
interesting character I can and make
myself different from everybody else and
that's that's the thing they continue to
do with path of Exile and in particular
with the awakening it's just how many
different ways can we make players happy
and one of the best ways to do that is
making really unique so instead of going
out there finding the best builds you
can by following some kind of tutorial
on the internet you go out there and you
do it yourself you find out what you can
make exercise your creativity and
chances are you're going to get
something pretty cool
you